>>> IT'S "WEEKEND UPDATE" WITH
COLIN JOST AND MICHAEL CHE.
>> GOOD EVENING, EVERYONE.
>> WELCOME TO "WEEKEND UPDATE."
I'M MICHAEL CHE.
>> COLIN JOST.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THIS WEEK MARKS TWO YEARS
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE FIRST
COVID LOCKDOWN AND LET'S JUST
SAY SOME PEOPLE HAVE HANDLED THE
STRESS BETTER THAN OTHERS.
RUSSIA HAS PASSED A FAKE NEWS
LAW THAT MAKES IT ILLEGEL FOR
ANY ORGANIZATION TO REPORT
INFORMATION THAT CONTRADICTS
WHAT THE GOVERNMENT SAYS.
WHICH EXPLAINS THE RECENT
HEADLINE, "BELOVED 6'5" PUTIN
HAS NOT GONE INSANE."
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN DOWN PLAYED
THE POSSIBILITY OF MILITARY
INTERVENTION, SAYING WE WILL NOT
FIGHT THE THIRD WORLD WAR.
WHICH I GET ON A POLITICAL
TO WATCH PUTIN BOMBING THINGS
LIKE SCHOOLS, A MATERNITY AWARD,
I'M JUST GOING TO ASSUME, PUPPY
DAYCARE CENTERS, AND NOT FEEL
ANYTHING.
THIS SITUATION HAS GOTTEN SO
UPSETTING I'VE THOUGHT ABOUT
MARCHING DOWN TO THE NEAREST
ARMY ENLISTMENT OFFICE AND
SIGNING CHE UP.
>> AFTER THE U.S. BAN ON RUSSIAN
OIL, GAS PRICES HIT A RECORD
HIGH OF $4.30.
WHICH IS SO EXPENSIVE, THAT WE
MIGHT HAVE TO MOVE BACK IN WITH
OUR EX.
COME ON, IRAQ.
YOU KNOW WE NEVER STOPPED LOVING
YOU, BABY.
RESPONDING TO SANCTIONS BY
BANNING THE EXPORT OF
RUSSIAN-MADE CARS.
BUT A RUSSIAN-MADE CAR IS JUST A
DRUNK BEAR ON ROLLER SKATES.
>> STARBUCKS HAS RESPONDED BY
SHUTTING DOWN LOCATIONS IN
RUSSIA, IN HOPES OF SENDING A
MESSAGE TO PRESIDENT VANDER PUMP
RENKEN?
>> AFTER McDONALD'S ANNOUNCED IT
WOULD STOP DOING BUSINESS IN THE
COUNTRY, RUSSIANS HAVE BEGUN
HOARDING THEIR SANDWICHES,
INCLUDING SOME HONORARY
RUSSIANS.
>>> CONGRESS PASSED A BILL THAT
MAKES LYNCHING A A FEDERAL HATE
CRIME PUNISHABLE BY UP TO 30
YEARS IN PRISON.
AND THEY'RE NOT MESSING AROUND.
YOU CAN GET 150 DAYS FOR JUST
MAKING ONE UP.
>>> DISNEY EMPLOYEES WERE UPSET
THAT THE COMPANY TOOK SO LONG TO
CONDEMN FLORIDA'S PROPOSED
"DON'T SAY GAY" BILL.
ALTHOUGH AT DISNEY, THEY
ACTUALLY DON'T SAY GAY, THEY SAY
TIMON M'PUMBAA.
>> FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS
SEEN HERE WAVING COVID INTO THE
CLUB ATTACKED DISNEY FOR
OPPOSING THE STATE'S DON'T SAY
GAY BILL, CALLING THE COMPANY A
WOKE CORPORATION.
DISNEY DENIED THE CLAIMS OF
WOKENESS WITH ROUGHLY 90 YEARS
OF CARTOONS.